Google is launching a new service called
inactive Account Manager and this is to
protect your digital self which in some
ways now in 2013 is more important than
your real organic self basically if you
die they're going to set up a system now
that will allow you to keep your digital
properties online for three six nine
months a year you'll be able to have it
all deleted if you want or you can pass
it along to another person that who then
can manage your living digital will I
guess we can call it does this seem
crazy we're so obsessed with this stuff
in our lives now we're gonna be obsessed
with it yeah our deaths the best
sentence was we hope that this new
feature will enable you to plan your
digital afterlife in a way that protects
you of my digital afterlife like
everything you're still you're just dead
then you're like character from cool I
got her to keep going on there from the
coffin they're gonna give you your
Twitter account yeah I assure you that
my tombstone is gonna be in 140
characters yes there you go yeah I mean
is this just completely crazy though
we're so obsessed with all this stuff
and now it's gonna community birthdays
from dead people on facebook I'll stay
together yeah you know because somebody
dies in their account will live forever
but I mean I'm involved with
reputation.com the online reputation
management company and one of the one of
the programs we have that's a very
challenging program and I don't know how
Google will get over this is how many
Dave rubens are there in the world um
there's you know probably hundreds as a
bunch of them this guy who's got dave
rubin calm I've been trying to get it
from him hate here we'll talk after the
show but no I'm telling you and it's
like so how do we get the right dave
rubin dived and then they're gonna kill
up the wrong dave rubin but i always
tell people information that's online
it's it's like herpes only it's going to
live longer than you do okay it really
does it it exists there is no statute of
limitations or online information yeah
do you
necessary though well yeah think about
it if I kick the bucket tomorrow I want
all my online I don't want anyone check
in my gmail I'm gonna shut down as yes I
wanted to be like you know this gmail
will self-destruct in five four get
clear everything I don't want to be like
some airline miles from what credit card
that you still want to use the jags you
said well what if you want give it to
you what is that even can you even do
that if you're alive or you'll have to
transfer those that's a whole that's a
whole lot better that's all they're
happy but what about your public stuff
so I can understand your email you want
shut down because that's your private
communication but what / when I died
okay what says I'm playing to let go
when her let it all go let it go yeah i
don't know how i feel about this because
i don't want anyone posted on my
facebook page like still missing Aaron
yeah just like but there was my family
gets just creepy it's creepy to me i
wanted i wanted to wiped out but in a
weird way wouldn't you want the people
who love Aaron Foley to have a space to
come to where they can all reminisce
about your fun with somebody like a
cemetery over a two digit people don't
want to visit the cemetery actually get
in the car into it somebody dies though
I see on facebook it's really kind of a
place to go wait here's the memorial and
it's here and you know but that's
assuming you know that somebody in your
family has your you know secret
passwords yeah so speaking of secret
passwords so what I find interesting and
I'm gonna give you my social security
what I fight interested in talking about
this is that you know one of the things
they say is you can give someone can be
like a custodian of all of your digital
assets but god only knows what would
happen you know people get into
financial problems three years later
maybe they want to sell your digital
asset I mean it just opens up this
endless Pandora's box of it also opens
up if you have a job where you're
overseeing the inactive Account Manager
that your job title could be director of
digital death yeah hey if that
facilitated oh they're here at Rydell
you know it has every morning you're
like oh really office Twitter youth
director of digital death Oh hamar to
pitch parties today yeah all right well
we had a nice shoes
bonobos calm is the official outfitter
of the Ruben report I want to put you in
this slim fit shirt go to bonobos com
enter code trr 20 for twenty percent off
your next purchase